i am very recently married so it was
about two months ago congratulations
that's great that's really nice yeah
yeah very exciting um so there's that
got that going for me what's this guy's
name can i know his name yes his name is
julian julian okay all right
yes he's a big he is a big fan he was
giving me some notes before this oh good
so possible things i could talk about so
i have this freudian urge now to fight
julian i don't know what that's all
about
i do i i don't know why i i feel like i
need to you don't know anything about
him no i'm not saying he's married to
emily exactly but i feel like i need to
to prove myself to emily by fighting
julian is that crazy yeah emily is that
crazy
i don't think it's crazy and not a fight
where anyone gets hurt but we just
rustle around a little bit and then we
just hold each other you're similar
okay well that took a turn that's a
whole new
look i'll talk it over with julian he
knows exactly what i'm talking about um
sure what does he do he um so he
actually has a degree a master's degree
in social work but he works in public
health right now it sounds like his
field is dangerously close to yours it
is very close to mine yes um
i
you know i was talking about this
earlier when we argue it's very um very
tactical almost annoyingly so sometimes
so you know um for instance i never do
the dishes i'm terrible at it so instead
of being like god why don't you ever do
the dishes we have to be like you don't
do the dishes it makes me feel sad i
don't like it oh no
yes yes oh so he's he's doing that he's
he's read all the handbooks you've read
oh but it's healthiest
it's also very it's annoying because
each of them
each of them are using all the tools you
know all the special tools and the tool
in the toolbox yeah this is how i feel
when you don't do the dishes do you know
what i mean yeah rather than just like
you slob do the dishes yeah but isn't
you slob do the dishes that's not
productive it's pretty good you get out
some anger you get to call you the other
person a slob also can i just call
[ __ ] on i'm not good at doing the
dishes that's what i say that's what i
say to my wife and she says what are you
talking about it's called rinsing the
plate you know and and and wiping it
clean uh a chimpanzee can do it when
people say i'm not good you know i'm not
i know but i'm just not good at flushing
the toilet that's not my thing it's
ridiculous let's probe your psychosis
here why are you refusing to do the
dishes when it's clearly something you
can do as a very intelligent grown
person right yeah man you've really
called me out i'm not gonna have to not
let julian listen to this
why aren't you doing the dishes emily um
i don't like to do them right so what
there's a lot of things we don't want to
do it sucks then your hands dry out i
get it i totally and the sponge smells
bad yeah so better he do it why why is
it okay for julian to do it but not you
he has a more specific way that he would
like them to be done so
there it is see there you go the rule is
like if you have a specific way you want
it done then perhaps you should do it
okay all right um you're standing up for
julian now and you wanted to fight him
like five minutes ago well i also said
it it wouldn't be a very vicious fight
it would be kind of a slap fight and
then we'd hold each other for a while
yeah and then you'd watch the dishes
and we'd wash the dishes together and
we'd uh we'd [ __ ] about emily what's
her deal man i know tell me about it
it's so strategic
and manipulative
you do that too sometimes to me what do
you mean when i went like when i would
sometimes forget to put like your travel
and phone your sometimes forget you'd be
like why do you forget and i'm like
maybe just because i'm a forgetful
person but you always thought there was
like a deeper thing there but sometimes
it's just well we later on found out
that you were chewing a lot of gummies
and so i think that's why your memory
went in the trash can but uh the other
day i had to take a trip and i looked
down at my uh iphone my whole itinerary
and everything was in there because
david had taken care of it thank you
david and i was shocked because that had
never happened before under the you also
were texting me not thinking it was in
there i texted you and said well can you
let me know and then i realized it was
already in there something that never
happened under the presidency of one
sona
emily can you dissect this for a second
oh this is just me stating fact there's
no psychological
uh you know who do going on here there
is abuse psychological abuse i would say
no
wait to hear emily's take on you two
well anyway we just didn't need to get
into that move
this is just a reasonable boss trying to
get his employee
to do pretty much what is their job
and they are refusing to do it
you